let's welcome tonight's guests he
performs for hospital patients to remind
them that things could be worse founder
of the loftusparty.com Michael Loftus
when she wants your opinion she'll give
it to you it's Fox News anchor Julie
Bandera
his writing's sharper than a machete
made of cheese novelist and literary
critic Walter Kerr
and finally she's like a pack of
cigarettes bad for your health but
popular with bikers Fox News contributor
tattoo
all right uh before we get to some news
stories it's Friday so let's do this
Greg's leftovers
yeah it's leftovers where I read the
jokes we didn't use this week and as
always it's my first time reading these
so if they suck I'll skin Joe Mackey
with a dull butter knife
be hard to tell though here we go
barisma executive Nicola zoltzefsky
allegedly said that Hunter Biden is
dumber than his dog
since his dog knows when to stop humping
his leg
that's not bad
oh here's another Joe and Hunter
allegedly coerced the barisma CEO to pay
them 5 million bucks each in return Joe
gave them political favors and Hunter
gave them scabies
Joe Biden started using a shorter set of
stairs to board Air Force One after he
kept falling on the regular stairs
so what will cushion his fall next time
depends
came up too soon
you like them you know
they're a proud sponsor to outnumbered
[Laughter]
I don't know why I choose them
them Harris still come after me a Burger
King manager in South Carolina was
arrested after serving a customer french
fries that were in a garbage can
suspicions about the fries were first
aroused when the customer noticed they
were actually warm
all right it's true huh
the wife of Long Island's Gilgo Beach
serial killer has filed for divorce
man that divorce is going to cost him an
arm and a leg
I know that's tasteless
it's terrible actually John fetterman
says his disastrous debate performance
quote lit the match on his depression
and we all know how he feels about fire
laughs
ABC announced uh 71 year old Jerry
Turner as the star of the golden
Bachelor needless to say Jerry will
spend the next two weeks trying to
figure out how to record the show on his
DVR
[Laughter]
that's our audience you're laughing at
they pay for these threads
Joe Jonas revealed this week that he
once accidentally did a number two in
his pants while on stage in response a
relief President Biden said you too
and you asked me
people ask me Greg do people really love
poop jokes there's your answer
political experts say the Democrats have
a shortage of male voters but they hope
to make it up with an influx of women
with penises
[Laughter]
that's funny because it's true
Barbie opens in theaters today although
because Ken has no male genitalia
audiences keep confusing him with Prince
Harry
[Applause]
tasteless the stifling heat continued in
Southern and central California this
week my phone is on it's so hot that in
Sacramento Governor Newsom is using fire
retardant hair gel
thousands of 10-inch penis fish have
washed up on a beach in Argentina a
spokesman for the fish claimed they're
actually longer but they've been in the
water all day
Marjorie Taylor green sparked outrage
during house hearings by showing
explicit photos from Hunter Biden's
laptop horrified Dems immediately seized
the images and sent them to the nearest
children's Library
that was good this week a tornado
wrecked a Pfizer plant in North Carolina
so it turns out God doesn't trust the
booster shots either
yeah
[Music]
and finally records show that LinkedIn
co-founder Reed Hoffman a one-time guest
on Jeffrey Epstein's pedophile Island
donated nearly 700 thousand dollars to
Joe Biden's campaign fund but I guess
700 Grand is mere Child's Play to him
okay to some news is the
attention-seeking mentality pushing
alternative sexuality according to the
New York Post owned by her parent
company Waffle House
students at ivy league universities are
identifying as non-straight as much as
five times as the general public a
recent poll from racistly named Brown
University claimed 38 of the student
body isn't straight and what about the
remaining 62 percent well they're
invited to my place this weekend
and other Ivy League schools have seen
large jumps in kids identifying as lgbtq
in recent years Princeton more than a
third Yale and Harvard more than a
quarter the one outlier is Penn just 15
but it's located in Philadelphia so
maybe they don't want to come out of the
closet due to all the gunfire
but many students on these campuses say
a fixation on identity politics is to
blame said one Princeton grad quote
since sexual orientation identity is
largely non-falsifiable many people will
claim lgbtq status to join the oppressed
group it could be that students at Elite
schools are more inclined to be obsessed
with social acceptance and professional
advancement
end quote
but not all college kids follow the
flock researchers at Northwestern
recently sent out gender surveys to
engineering students at a bunch of
schools and the responses were
delightful to say the least several kids
identified as Apache attack helicopters
another a cisgender lizard King
and another listed their race as Native
American Elizabeth Warren
researchers called the responses
evidence that fascism is on the rise in
America but if refusing to answer
questions about your sexuality is
fascism then I'm Benito Mussolini
yeah see I didn't say Hitler
I'm learning but this proves that
instead of salivating over everything
LGBT maybe those researchers should STFU
hahaha
Walter what do you make of this trend is
it because college kids are just
essentially dumb and will follow
anything
well I went to Princeton so I can tell
you uh that things really haven't
changed because no matter what people
are calling themselves what they really
are is virgins
that's true I love you know people go to
Princeton to tell people they go to
Princeton exactly and they're far too
busy to have sex with each other so uh
but yes how do you get into Ivy League
colleges by pleasing your teachers right
uh by pleasing authority figures so uh
they've been very good at this their
whole lives since kindergarten they've
raised their hand they've you know
erased the chalkboard they've done
everything that Society wants of them
and now they're doing another thing that
Society wants of them but but the real
difference is that when I was at
Princeton they didn't ask me about my
sexual orientation and nor would I have
answered
um I probably would have taken the
Apache attack helicopter I like that too
yeah but what's fascist about Apache
Attack Helicopters they're going around
the world spreading freedom and
democracy they're actually the most
Progressive attack helicopters on Earth
um
but you know what it is it's it's Apache
and that is cultural appropriation these
helicopters need to apologize to Liz
Warren well I know a few of patches and
they're pretty damn proud to have an
attack helicopter
all right uh Julie so I have a theory
would you like to hear it
the reason the the reason this is
happening is because the barrier to
entry is so low right all it requires no
effort everybody has to believe you and
it's replacing actual self-improvement
which is why all the college students
are so homely because they no longer go
to the gym they don't care about their
appearance because they just choose a
pronoun don't you think that's brilliant
no
remember it's his show yeah
it's brilliant you must have spent hours
preparing for that I did it your writers
did a good job no I have to say that I
think this is just part of our like woke
culture where they are trying to nurture
over nature I mean they're basically
trying to teach kids that it is the norm
to be gay and so when people go into
college they want to be accepted
obviously so they pretend that they're
gay so I guess that's the whole thing
like we're all a little bit gay like
look at cat tonight she's so hot right
hey guys
like I've always had dreams about Barbie
and now it's like coming true I mean I
don't know my next sleepover with Kat is
going to be different next time oh my
goodness
I mean it's cool to
cool too so yeah
I actually identify as a heterosexual
male but you already know that yeah but
tonight I am a lesbian yes
Loftus identifies as a homeless Tracy
Chapman yes I have a fast car
and you live in it
when it's run
uh I think these ivy league kids are
brilliant I think they're really smart
I'm with you on this one it's a get get
it's a wonderful uh get out of jail free
card right you don't have to work on
yourself you don't have to be special if
you fail at anything you're like it's
because I'm trans exactly and you can
blame society for not for not fitting in
and like when I finish talking for this
little response to the whole trans thing
I want the audience to consider that I
am trans and what I just said was very
brave
[Laughter]
a little slow
thank you thank you that took courage
that took courage you are you are a hero
you are a hero I don't I don't consider
myself I just want to get on my knees
right now
again again
terrible cat what do you make of the
Apache attack helicopter as a as a
gender identification
I think that not all of this has to do
with how people think about gender
identification and some of it has to do
with how people feel about paperwork
the forms are so long like the forms are
already so long we need to add another
thing when less than one percent of the
population identifies as trans I mean I
went to my dentist the other day how
many times do I have to tell them that
no I still do not suffer from
incontinence and also what does it have
to do with my teeth and gums the forms
and they're like how many times I have
to give them my email it's like you guys
email me all the time you have my email
you're like and happy National tooth
month you know like how to keep your
teeth clean this Halloween like the
forms are already like six or seven
pages long of things that have nothing
to do with anything the last thing we
need to do is be adding more things to a
form because you know what we're all
dying we should live our lives while we
have a chance there you go
live our lives
[Applause]
it is well now that they don't require
the SAT at Ivy League colleges they have
the lgdpq plus and it is long and it's
very easy yeah um you just say all of
the above yes exactly that's true I am
I'm wtta
willing to try anything
instead of barking off you know white
Caucasian Hispanic it's like top or
bottom
I always just write down I'm the filling
[Laughter]
if you're laughing then you understood
that joke
if you're not laughing you're a good
person
up next we discuss what's really going
on with aliens in the pen hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else